foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar
considerations to limit off Target edits
in your Gene editing experiments my name
is pandita poshnad and I'm the senior
product manager at Thermo Fisher
Scientific and I'll be your moderator
for today's event
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
Send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and offers
free continuing education credits please
click on the window at the bottom of
your screen to obtain your credits
I'd now like to welcome our speaker
Kevin pritam field application
scientists at Thermo Fisher Scientific
supporting the gene modulation and
editing portfolio
Kevin obtained his PhD from Virginia
Tech in translational biology medicine
and health he has over 14 years of
research experience in cancer biology
drug development drug delivery and
neurobiology
please join me in welcoming Kevin
oh good morning good afternoon and good
evening everyone and thank you for
joining today my name is Kevin purdom I
am a field application scientist with
Thermo Fisher Scientific and today I'm
going to be talking about considerations
to limit off-target edits in your Gene
editing experiments
so just a brief overview of everything
we're going to cover today we're going
to talk about engineered nucleases the
problems of off-target edits strategies
to limit those off-target edits we'll go
over some example experiments
tips and tricks for improving your Gene
editing experiments and then we'll wrap
everything up with a summary
so what is gene editing and how is it
done so generating editing basically is
adding DNA replacing DNA or removing DNA
this is all done to generate animal
disease models for tissue disease
modeling stem cell engineering leading
up to potential Gene therapies and novel
cell-based therapies for fighting
disease as well as working in plants to
make disease resistant and transgenic
plants and crops
so how is this typically done this is
done utilizing engineered nucleases
which essentially are molecular scissors
that are leveraged to edit the
chromosome at a user-defined site this
involves using these nucleases to make
double-stranded DNA breaks that then
open up the DNA for the potential for
editing this is typically done using
crispr or using Talons and we'll go over
both of those a little bit here next
so the crispr cas9 system is an
rna-guided DNA nuclea system that was
identified as a bacterial adaptive
response pathway against bacteriophage
infection
this system comprises of two parts which
is the cas9 protein which in our cartoon
here is the giant green blob the kas9
protein has the actual job of cutting
the DNA
this is complexed with a guide rnae
molecule that is actually two pieces of
guide of RNA that are stitched together
the first is the crispr RNA or the crrna
that consists of 20 nucleotides that
match up to the exact region of the
genome that you are trying to make your
edit at
guide RNA piece of the crisper part is
matched up with a tracer RNA
the Tracer RNA has the job of bringing
cas9 in to the genome forming the
complex so that cas9 can make a cut
the next important part with crispr
based editing is the Pam sequence or the
protospacer adjacent motif
in the case of s pyogenes chas9 which is
typically a most used version the Pam
sequence is ngg which is any nucleotide
base followed by two guanines
typically cas9 will make a blunt-ended
cut as represented by the little
scissors in the cartoon three
nucleotides away from the Pam site
sometimes there can be a little bit of a
wobble and you'll have one overhang
nucleotide base but typically it's a
blunt ended break
and then cas9 can be delivered as well
as the guide RNA molecules can be
delivered into cells via plasmid RNA or
the ribonucleoprotein approach which
we'll get into that in a little bit
so next are talents so a Talon is a Tau
effector nuclease Tau effector proteins
are produced in bacteria most namely
xanthamonus
cows consist of variable numbers of
amino acid repeats each repeat contains
33 to 35 amino acids and recognizes a
single DNA base pair
thus there is a chance for high
customization and limitation of
off-target editing
Talon pairs can be introduced into
eukaryotic cells via plasmid or as mRNA
molecules
Talons always consist as two parts a
forward and a reverse Talon to get the
upper and the lower strand of DNA and
they are fused to an endonuclease these
endonucleases become active when they
dimerize with each other and then
they're laying on top of the DNA at the
site that you want to cut and they will
cleave the DNA when a Talon makes a cut
typically it forms sticky ends or have a
four or five base pair overhang on
either end where the cut occurs
so when you're performing Gene editing
with engineer nucleases
it leads to formation of a
double-stranded DNA break which you can
imagine sets off a bunch of alarm Bells
inside of the cell
there's many different DNA repair
Pathways that get activated the most
common is nhej or non-homologous end
joining this is a very fast and
efficient way of repairing DNA that has
been cleaved but sometimes it does make
an error but we can utilize that error
generation for ourselves in our own
research this is done when a premature
stop codon or a nonsense or missense
mutation is formed that leads to a
non-functional protein or turns off a
gene this is really good if you're
trying to do knockout models or do lots
of function studies or do high
throughput functional genomic screening
the other way of repair involves a
knock-in where you actually are knocking
in a piece of DNA that you want in the
site where the edit occurred this could
be a fluorescent marker onto a protein
so you can image it in live cells or
this could be a actual single nucleotide
polymorphism edit or an SNP so you can
generate a disease model
um this involves a homology directed
repair where in the example here we have
this little blue cassette which is our
piece of DNA that we want to add and
that is flanked by homology arms on the
left and the right hand side these are
complementary to the DNA site where the
edit is occurring and this helps
increase the chances of the new cassette
being Incorporated and added
so with the power that Gene editing has
there's an emerging concern for
off-target editing
this is important to think about because
these off-target events are of course
unintended they happen and there's
potential for adding other variables or
unknowns into your experiments this is
also very important if you are working
in the translational research realm or
trying to move towards the clinic to
generate novel Southeast or Gene
therapies whereby you need to be
thinking about if there's any off-target
edits happening and of course the FDA
has put out guidance about a year ago
almost now where they are starting to
look for off-target analysis in new
cell-based therapy applications that
they are reviewing
so there's different kinds of unwanted
or off-target edits that can occur in
your Gene editing experiments
the first and most common and the one
that we're going to talk about today is
when cas9 can cut sequences that are
similar to the Target sequence or in our
box on the left hand side of the screen
where you can see that we have at the
top hour in the green box is our guide
RNA that is specifically set to Target
fit region on chromosome 20. but you can
see in the list that there's potential
for that guide RNA to match up at other
locations within the genome and
potentially increase the risk for an
off-target edit to be formed
other types of unwanted untar or
unwanted edits are transpositions
between cuts where you might get a piece
of a chromosome matching up and be
incorporated with another piece of a
different chromosome like a swap between
chromosome 20 and chromosome 10. the
other is if you're doing knock-ins and
you are actually trying to add a piece
of DNA in your donor for example here
gets inserted into the wrong site in
another location within the genome
another edit that's unwanted is a large
deletion whereby a huge chunk of the
area where you're doing an edit might
get removed
these other forms of off targets do
happen but they're usually a relatively
low percentage the one that has the most
risk and high chance for an off-target
edit is when your guide RNA matches up
to another location within the genome
so as represented by this cartoon we
have on the left our On Target duplex
which is our guide RNA it has a perfect
match with the target DNA site where we
want the edit to occur on the right hand
side is potential mismatches where our
guide RNA is matching up pretty well at
other locations within the genome it's
Bar for a couple of mismatches as you
can see there but there's still chance
because of this High matching rate that
cas9 could make a cut at these
off-target sites
so why is considering off-target editing
important so when I think about this I
think about the typical type of models
that folks are doing for their research
are either cell based models or more
larger animal models or 3D disease
models and then of course for clinical
and translational research
so in thinking about these three fields
off Target edits are very important
namely that the observed phenotype that
you are trying to observe by doing the
editing experiment could be thrown off
by an off-target edit whereby you think
that you've changed a molecular
signaling pathway and lo and behold an
off-target edit changed another
Downstream signaling pathway that you
didn't consider at first and that
completely changes your results of your
experiments
um there's also been a change in the
research funding field where a lot of
different funding agencies are starting
to ask about off-target edits in their
Grant review process or in the process
of even submitting an application where
they will want a pitfalls and solutions
section on if you are attempting to do
Gene editing what you will do if you are
seeing off targets if your experiment's
not working or they just will require
that to be in there in order for them to
review it
um the same is happening with scientific
journals a lot of journals are starting
to ask for full off-target analysis to
be provided as a uploaded document with
a journal article if you generated some
cell models in the paper
um so you can prove that the cell model
that you generated doesn't have any
off-target edits and that the results
that are observed are true and lastly
especially in the clinical and the
translational research realm safety and
toxicity is extremely important and
off-target editing can have effects on
that as well as health Regulators like
the FDA and the European EMA are asking
for these types of analyzes to be
performed on cell and Gene Therapies
so what are some strategies that we can
take in the lab when we're doing our
experiments and in the planning phases
to limit or reduce off-target edits
first is by using a high scoring guide
RNA
so what does that mean so in the crispr
space there are many different rules and
algorithms that have been designed for
predicting the ability of a guide RNA to
have very strong on-target editing
efficiency while also limiting its
ability to bind at other locations
within the genome to create an
off-target edit
the Thermo Fisher has worked really hard
to design its own algorithm system for
developing guide rnas
so the way that this system works is
it's first going to ask you where in the
genome are you trying to do your edit
and you will then simply tell it it will
tell it the Gene and then you will show
the actual location where you want to
perform your edit
the system will then for example here
let's say this is the region of the
genome that we want to do our edit it
will then scan that specific region for
potential guide rnas specifically you
see the blue arrows there that are all
numbered are potential guides and then
the red boxes are those ever important
Pam sites for cas9
the system will then rank those out
based off a series of different
Criterion and then assign a score
part of that scoring process takes into
account the complexity of the sequence
of that guide RNA so does that guide RNA
have very strong matching to the site
that you want to edit specifically
does it bind to or match up to other
locations within the genome if it does
how many times does it do that and then
if it does are there any mismatches
it will then look at the GC content of
the particular guide RNA sequence
because that increases the guide rna's
stability inside of the cell
it then will look for the nucleotide
positional preference which is is this
guide RNA matching up close enough to
the exact site where you are trying to
do your edit because that is also
important so it's not going to design a
guide RNA that's often Timbuk2 which is
where you don't care if you're trying to
Target a specific site then lastly it
looks for the pan sequence is it in a
good spot is it based off the sequence
and different algorithmic designs is the
cutting ability increased based off
editing at this site as opposed to
another one slightly to the left or
slightly to the right
it will then take all of those guides
and give a list of ones that are
appropriate for you to use in your
experiments so you see here we have our
acceptable and our high potential off
targets and so the last piece of the
scoring is by looking at the seed region
so with a guide RNA where it lays down
on the specific site within the genome
the sequence of the guide that is just
past the Pam sequence is called the seed
region
the seed region is the most important
because if that is a 100 match cas9 has
a greater propensity to come in and make
a cut you can see for the guide rnas
that have the green check marks next to
them we see for the first guide RNA that
it does not match up anywhere else in
the genome so that's a very good guide
you can see for the other one here that
has an exact match to the seed region
but it doesn't have a Pam sequence
that's relevant to cas9 so that's also a
good guide the other two where the
little blue boxes are are mismatches in
the seed region if you have mismatches
in the seed region there's a greater
chance that kas9 cannot get in there and
make a cut which is why our algorithm
says these are good and then you can see
for the ones that have the red X's they
either have a the C region is an exact
match or the Pam site isn't good so they
are automatically kicked out based off
of our systems roles
so where does this algorithm live it
lives and runs on our true design genome
editing software which is a web
browser-based system that is a very
powerful and fun and easy to use tool
for designing your Gene editing
experiments it simply works by asking
you to search for the gene it asks you
what type of experiment are you doing
you craft the edit and then it goes
through and it designs the guides
so for example this is kind of what
you'll see the first piece it asks you
what type of experiment are you going to
be doing we support Gene Knockouts as
well as doing Gene tagging with either
fluorophores or even with a tag like a
flag or a mick tag for pull downs we
also support insertions and deletions as
well as single nucleotide polymorphism
edits which are very important for
disease modeling research
then it will ask you what host organism
or cell type are you using we support
human mouse rat zebrafish and roundworm
once you tell it that it will ask you
what the gene is or if you know the
exact DNA sequence or the actual
location you can type that in if you
choose the gene symbol you just simply
type in the gene which in this case for
example we're looking at Gap DH
if there's multiple transcripts of a
gene it will list them and then you
simply click on the one that you're
looking to edit and you'll click the
next button
it will then ask you based off what type
of experiment you pick more of the
parameters where exactly do you want the
set it to occur and you will simply
scroll through and find the exact site
within an exoner and intron of the gene
of Interest
and then it will run the analysis and
scan for guides once that scan is done
it will give you a list as you see here
for example and it will rank them based
off of that score so you see for our
first guide RNA it has a score of 95
percent and then it has a list of
potential off targets if you click on
each individual number it will give you
a list of those off targets so the key
pieces that you need to take into
consideration when looking at your
guides are highlighted in the red box
here is the overall score and the off
targets the score is based on the
uniqueness of that guide RNA and its
potential for off-target cutting or the
risk
just because a guide RNA has potential
off targets as you can see here it
doesn't mean that they will always have
a cut occur at those sites there's many
different things that can affect this so
it's just helping you get an idea on
what the risk is
for this example
once you've picked your guide rnas for
your experiment the true design system
takes you to a nice summary page where
you're able to design and order
everything that you need for your Gene
editing experiment this includes if you
are ordering guides if you need a donor
DNA homology arms are automatically
designed by the system so you don't have
to do it yourself required reagents are
there as well as gcd or genomic cleavage
detection primers and sequencing primers
are designed for you as well as it makes
suggestions for positive and negative
controls which are extremely important
in your Gene entity experiments lastly
if you click on that download designs
and protocols button it will download an
Excel file that summarizes all of the
guide RNA sequences that it generated
these specific site mutation or edit
that you're trying to make as well as
list out suggested reagents and
suggested protocols to help you get
started once you're starting to do your
experiments
so by using an insilico design tool like
true design to identify potential
off-target loci we can limit off-target
edits there are some limitations to this
though if you are operating in an area
of the genome that doesn't have any Pam
sites which is kind of rare but it does
happen or if the guide rnas that are
designed have a low score or high off
Target profile
there's a couple little backup plans
that we can take to get to fix that
so our next strategy to limit off-target
edits is using the rnp delivery format
so when crispr started out it started as
using DNA plasmid vectors that were
transfected into your cells the plasmid
of course coded for the chasmine enzyme
as well as the individual guide RNA that
you were trying to express
you would then transfect that plasmid
into your cell of interest and rely on
the cell's translation and transcription
Machinery to read and form the mature
guide RNA as well as the mature and
active cas9 enzyme the field then moved
towards using synthetic guides that are
synthesized via ivt or in vitro
transcription as well as using mRNA that
codes for cas9 which you would then
transfect into your cells again you
would rely on the Machinery of the cell
to produce the mature cas9 enzyme which
would then go off and do the editing
now the field is using the rnp or the
ribonucleoprotein approach which
involves using cas9 that has already
been purified and is active you then
couple that with a synthetic guide RNA
outside of the cell
form that complex and then you deliver
that assembled complex directly inside
of your cell of Interest so that you can
go straight it can go straight to work
and start editing you're no longer
relying on the Machinery of the cell to
do the work for you
there's also some added benefits with
the rmp approach which I'm hoping that
I'll be able to summarize here
which is in this case we have cells that
were treated with either plasma DNA
expressing for cas9 mRNA expressing for
cas9 or cas9 protein itself and then
monitored via Western blot over time for
degradation of the protein you can see
in the case of the DNA that we started
out very low because of course we had to
give the cells time to make the kas9
enzyme and then you can see that the
Expressions stayed very high and that
stayed consistent across the board
is something that happens when you use
plasma you get constitutive expression
of cas9 with the MRNA approach we got
expression of cas9 pretty early but it
was it was relatively low and then it of
course degraded
with the rmp or the protein approach you
can see that we got very high robust
amounts of cas9 inside of the cells
early on and then over time that chas9
degraded and cleared from the cells
so this is important when you start
thinking about off-target editing so you
can see here in this graph we have two
different clones of cells ot3-2 and
ot3-18 and we're looking at off slash On
Target ratio
with the three different forms of cas9
delivery you can appreciate with the
black bars that the DNA plasmid has
higher off-target generation in
comparison to On Target generation
whereas with the RNA approach in the
blue you can see that it went down but
there's still a relatively high amount
of off-target generation within the
cells whereas with the protein-based
approach you can see especially in the
in the
ot318 cologne that you have very low off
Target generation and that's because the
protein went in it made the edit and
then it cleared
the other thing that's important with
the rnp approach is there's lower
toxicity than when you use plasmid or
mRNA for certain cell types transfecting
in a plasmid or an mRNA molecule can be
very toxic to cells whereas with the rnp
approach this toxicity is not observed
the other key thing here is for this
experiment a poor guide RNA was utilized
to help Force for off targets to occur
so you can see in the case of our ot318
clone of cells with a poor guide RNA but
coupled with the rnp approach we are
able to limit the off Target generation
in the genome even with a bad guide
so with the MRNA and the plasma approach
you get a more sustained level of cas9
or guide RNA expression but that stays
transient and then cas9 is present and
can create more off-target edits with
the rmp approach the level of crispr
cas9 is initially very high and then it
rapidly decays
so our next strategy for preventing or
reducing off-target edits is using an
appropriate endonuclease
so I would be remiss if I did not talk a
little bit about Thermo Fisher's cas9
proteins and why they are the best for
you to utilize in your Gene editing
experiments
so first is our invitrogen true cut cas9
protein V2 we are on V2 because our r d
group is constantly working to better
increase the performance of our cas9
enzymes while also looking at off-target
profile
so this version is engineered to give it
very high specificity
it allows for consistently High editing
efficiency in all different types of
cells tested that includes not only cell
lines but primary cells immune cells and
stem cells it's manufactured under
strict quality standards and we have
validated protocols for many many
different cell types that you can
download and take a look at to help set
up your experiments so you can achieve
your results faster
so for example here just a little bit of
data with our wild type true cut V2
protein we have two different cell lines
that are being treated with either our
version of cas9 or leading competitors
cas9 for three different Gene targets
and you can appreciate that our chasmine
performs at a much higher editing
efficiency in comparison to the leading
competitor
so in thinking about off-target editing
our r d group was thinking about ways
that they could change cas9 to give it a
better off-target editing profile such
that it can eliminate off-target editing
so there's this inverse relationship
between cas9's activity and its
specificity whereas cas9 as its
specificity goes up its activity goes
down
so our r d group was wondering if they
could identify a cas9 that lives in this
red region on the graph that has very
high editing specificity but still
maintains High editing activity
so to do this they set to work to
develop a new cas9 protein
in testing it and identifying potential
new enzymes that would be good for this
they performed experiments using bad
guide rnas so for example here you see
we have a guide RNA that's for the heck
4 Gene but it's got a bunch of potential
off Target binding at other locations
within the genome again they use this
guide intentionally so you can see here
with our wild type cas9 because of this
poor guide RNA design there's high
levels of off Target Cuts elsewhere
within the genome
when looking at a leading competitor's
High Fidelity cas9 in the same
experiment you can see that
it was able to reduce the off-target
edits as well as get many down to zero
but of course that's not acceptable we
need to get more zeros on that graph so
our r d group worked with a bunch of
different mutants of cas9 and finally
settled on this one which was able to in
this same experiment eliminate the off
Target Generation by 75 percent
so this cas9 went on to become of course
with much further testing our Hi-Fi cas9
protein
so this version is an offshoot of its
wild type version our true cut cas9
protein that has been specifically
modified to increase its specificity for
on-target cutting while also eliminating
its ability to bind it up off Target
locations
so it has a much better off-target
profile in comparison to the leading
competitors
so I've got a little bit of data to kind
of demonstrate this here so in this
graph you are seeing we're looking at
primary T cells that were treated with
guide rnas for four different genes with
three different cas9 proteins so we see
at the top here we have our truecut cas9
V2 protein a competitor's High Fidelity
cas9 and then our true cut Hi-Fi cas9
protein you've got the four different
genes there cd52 track a and track B and
pd1 the red dots are on target edits the
numbers on top of them are the different
guide rnas that were used and then all
of those gray dots are off Target edits
that were generated within the genome
and the type of analysis that is being
done here is called take seek which is
an improved version of guide seek that
is a whole genome analysis that looks
for off-target edit sites
so I'm going to modify the figure here a
little bit
and put some green boxes here so you can
kind of guide your eyes a little bit
easier so where the green boxes are are
sights and guide rnas that had no
off-target edits or very low ratio of
less than 0.1 percent
so you can see and then we counted up
the number of guides that had zero off
Target edits in the case of the wild
type cas9 you can see that there were
nine guide rnas that had zero off Target
generation
with a leading competitors High Fidelity
cas9 there were 11. with our Hi-Fi cas9
we were able to get 14 guide rnas that
generated zero off-target edits
the other important thing that this
figure is demonstrating is the power of
having a good guide RNA if you couple a
good guide RNA that has a very low off
Target profile and high binding
efficiency for the Target site and you
couple that with either a strong cas9
enzyme like our wild type kas9 or with
our HiFi cas9 you are able to rest easy
at night knowing that you did not
generate any off-target edits
so of course when researchers are
thinking about translating their
research From the Bench into the clinic
there's four distinct steps that you
have to go through that involves early
research and development and then
pre-clinical studies and then moving
into clinical trials and then eventually
the clinic and commercialization
during that pipeline the needs and wants
change in the reagents so to help
support this Thermo Fishers worked on
generating A cas9 protein that is both
high quality
high amount has high scalability and
meets GNP compliance so this protein is
our CTS true cut cas9 protein it is
produced under stringent manufacturing
conditions so that it can be utilized in
Cell Therapy type situations for
generating novel cell and Gene therapies
of the future
it is produced in large amounts and has
stringent testing requirements that it
must meet before it is released
um my email is listed on the bottom of
all the slides if anyone has any
specific questions about this cas9
please feel free to reach out to me
um I'm also really happy to be able to
mention here with you today that our r d
group is in the final stages of
developing a CTS Hi-Fi cas9 protein that
will be manufactured under the same
conditions as this wild-type cas9
protein is the same stringent testing
and performance results that must be met
in order for the lot to be released is
going to be applied to the Hi-Fi cas9 we
will have some versions of the CTS HiFi
cas9 protein ready for testing later
this year again if you might be
interested in testing being an early
tester please let us know
our r d group always loves to send out
samples to people and get it tested and
then report the results back so they can
make sure that it's performing the same
way that it is in their own hands in the
lab
selects a little bit with talents so the
unique thing about talents is there's no
sequence restrictions and that's kind of
being demonstrated in this little figure
here on the left so you have this DNA
sequence in each of the Red Arrows is a
potential cut site with a Talon you can
literally design a talent to cut at all
of those sites right there and that's
summarized in the little colored boxes
those are different Talon pairs so you
have High customs customizability
so that is demonstrated here in this
little example figure on the right so
this is Exon one of the track aging it
is 70 base pairs long and you can see
that there's some gray arrows on the top
all of those gray Arrow sites are cut
sites that a Talon can be designed to
cut at
the bottom arrows are sites where crispr
can cut because again crispr is limited
by a Pam sequence
now that's not to say that Talon is
better than crispr it has to do with the
exact type of edit that you were trying
to perform
crispr is of course Very powerful but if
you're operating in an area where there
is no Pam sequence or a Pam site is way
too far away from the area that you're
trying to make and edit a Talon might be
worthy of trying
so to summarize with using an
appropriate endonuclease so either using
a kas9 enzyme variant with either High
editing efficiency or high specificity
based off your needs or using a Talon if
you're operating in a Pam desert
so now we'll kind of Step through a
couple little examples here so let's say
we're using true design to design an
experiment we want to knock out a gene
and this is the screen that we get to on
the summary page so we've generated we
figured out the area that we want to do
our edit it's given us a list of guide
rnas which are seen here typically for
with true design it will recommend two
or three guides and I usually tell folks
when they're doing a crispr experiment
to use two or three guide rnas
especially when they're starting out so
they can identify which guide RNA
performs the best in their cell type and
gives them the best results that they're
looking for
as well as helping to make your research
more rigorous by having a different
guide RNA sequence that's targeting the
same gene so you can prove that you've
gotten a successful knockout or a
knock-in for example
so in this case we have a guide RNA that
has zero off targets and a score of 100
so that is a great potential guide RNA
sequence to use
then we have ones here that have a score
of 97 with four five or one off Target
now just because true design is listing
off targets does not mean that that off
Target is going to generate every time
you do your crispr experiment there's
just a chance for it but the chance is
very low given how high that guide RNA
score is typically if a guy RNA score is
above 60 percent there's still
relatively low risk that an off-target
edit will occur
let's look at another example let's say
we're still doing the same thing we want
to knock out a gene we have very good
scoring guide rnas but we see that the
number of off targets has increased with
these examples here so we've got an 89
and an 86 score which is still a very
good score which means that that guide
has a very high chance for an on-target
cutting while also having a low
off-target chance or risk for cutting
but if you're a little worried about
that high off Target number this might
be a good opportunity for you to use our
true cut Hi-Fi cas9 protein or if you
want to use a wild type cas9 then you
will just need to do some further
validation on the back end to make sure
that you didn't generate any off-target
edits
and lastly let's say we're operating in
this intron region where we want to do
an SNP which is highlighted in that
little blue box there and this is we
don't have any options this is exactly
where we want this edit to occur so true
design goes through and it scans and it
did generate guide rnas however they
were so poorly scored that the system
didn't even want to give them to you
because it knows that this is not good
so you see at the top there that we have
the other option for talents so if you
click on that tab you will then see that
the system designed talents that flank
the site again where you are
specifically needing to make that edit
what's really nice with the talent pairs
is it synthesizes them for you it will
then also design the donor DNA because
in this case we're doing an SNP so we
need to utilize homology directed repair
to insert this little piece of DNA that
includes this new mutation that we want
for our disease modeling for example so
true design goes through and it designs
those homology arms for the left and the
right hand side including the new
mutation that you're adding in
and then of course when you port this
out it will send the sequence for
synthesis because you don't need to
double check it it's going to translate
correctly
so what are some other tips and tricks
that I have for improving your Gene
editing experiments because we've talked
a lot about guide RNA we've talked a lot
about the cas9 but of course if you're
not able to successfully deliver those
into your cells then nothing's going to
work
so the first and foremost way that
Therma Fisher has for providing for
delivery to cells is through lipoectomy
or lipid-based transfection so if you
are utilizing mRNA to express your
chasmine you could use messenger Max to
deliver the MRNA into your cells if
you're using the rnp format we have our
crispr Max lipo fectamine reagent which
is able to deliver the fully assembled
cas9 rmp into your cells
if you're working with more finicky or
difficult cells to transfect like ipscs
or primary cells then you might want to
use electroporation which of course
involves making small tiny holes with
electricity to form pores in the
membrane which then would allow your
mRNA or your cas9 rmp to pass through
the membrane and enter the cell
so to support electroporation we have
our neon and what will be coming later
this month is the neon next this is the
first little image of it
um the neon next it operates the same as
the classic neon that's been around for
a long time
um it's a very great little
electroporation tool
um the main difference is the pipette
has been completely modified to make it
easier for you to get those ever
difficult tips to attach it's a lot
easier now and then of course we have
our Xenon which is the Big Brother of
the neon the Xenon is great if you are
trying to do really high amounts of
electroporation runs on cells up to 1.5
trillion cells per run the Neo the Xenon
can do that so we have support for all
different sized of experiments that
you're doing
the next tip that I have for you is make
sure your cells are healthy healthy
cells can make it through the genetic
process a lot better than ones that are
stressed out because of course the whole
entire genetic process stresses cells
out so optimizing the culturing
conditions for yourselves is very
important before you start doing these
types of experiments and then also
optimizing the plating densities the
seating densities because cells behave
differently if they're overgrown for
example or undergrown which can affect
the efficiency of your Gene editing
next is using controls please use
controls both positive and negative they
are extremely important because they
help you as the researcher understand if
your experiment is working or not the
positive controls are great because they
have very high efficiency for some
random Gene that's not important like
aav1 and human cells
that Gene will get cleaved you can
measure that that will help you optimize
conditions for growing your cells so
that if you see really low editing
efficiency at a certain cell density
with your positive control increase the
number of cells increase the way that
you take care of them try editing again
if you see an increase in the editing
efficiency then utilize those
optimizations when you actually deliver
your guide RNA and cas9 for the gene of
Interest so you can increase your
chances of getting good on target
editing
and lastly don't reinvent the wheel
Thermo Fisher has many protocols and app
nodes to help you in designing your Gene
editing experiments these are all
available for free the protocols are
step by step they even give you
concentrations of different reagents the
number of cells electroporation
parameters use them they're all there to
help you get your genetic experiments
done faster so you can move on to
getting your results
so the next important step is verifying
your editing results so you've designed
your experiment you transfect your cells
next is verifying that the edit that you
want has occurred and then screening for
off-target edits now the approach that
you take is going to depend on the type
of experiment that you're doing
so for example here let's go back to our
beginning models of cells so if you're
just doing a pool of cells just to do a
quick knockout you might not need to do
as much of a vigorous off-target
analysis
as you would if you're doing a disease
model for example let's say we used a
guide RNA from that example earlier that
had zero off targets
I would just use it and go with it if
you've got one that has a very high
score it has a low off Target number you
could generate primers and perform
genomic cleavage detection which is able
to detect for off-target editing
essentially the way that the gcd assay
works is you do your editing in your
cells you then collect the cells usually
about 24 to 48 hours post editing you
then collect the genomic DNA and you do
a PCR amplification and you couple that
with primers that flank the editing
sites both the On Target and the
potential off Target edit site you then
amplify those indels and you run them
out on a gel and the gel will look
something similar like this where you
see in for Target one and Target Two
when the detection enzyme is present you
see those little clip bands forming that
means that a cut occurred at those sites
so this would be a quick and easy way
for you to Target and identify any off
targets if your number is pretty low of
course if you've got like 30 potential
off targets you probably don't want to
design primers and do 30 gcd analyzes so
that might be a situation where you want
to perform Sanger sequencing or next
Generation sequencing with singer
sequencing you could utilize our system
called seek screener which is able to
Overlay all of the sequencing results in
comparison to your backbone or your
normal genome and it can identify indole
formation
so for those that are doing more
advanced models like animal and disease
modeling or clinical translational
research you're going to want to be a
lot more rigorous in how you identify
off Targets in screen for them so first
and foremost is going to be clonal
isolation where you do your edit and
then you plate those cells down to one
per one cell per well and like a 96 volt
plate or a 384 well plate you then let
those colonies grow and then you perform
analysis on each individual clone
looking at whole genome analysis via
Next Generation sequencing and then you
follow that by Downstream
characterization whether that is growing
those cells in 3D or generating an
animal model
or further characterization through
animal studies
so to help with this and with all of
your validation edits and steps that are
needed Therma Fisher has a series of
services that we could provide to you
where we do all of the analysis for you
first is for on and off target analysis
via Next Generation sequencing just
simply sequencing the entire Genome of
the cells that you've edited and looking
for off targets next is our more robust
and high throughput system called take
seek which was used in developing our
HiFi cas9 which is an unbiased whole
genome analysis for off-target
evaluation that can identify off-target
indel formation
and lastly is looking at chromosomal
changes did any large deletions occur
while this is rare this can be very
important if you're working with stem
cells and with stem cells in mind we
have a plethora of characterization and
validation services that can help you in
making sure after you've done editing to
your stem cells that they are still
performing and acting like stem cells
that involves checking and making sure
that there were no large chromosomal
translocations or deletions checking and
making sure that no off-target edits
were generated in an oncogene such that
in a protologcogene such that you
generate an oncogene or over activate a
pathway and then making sure that the
stem cells still genomically are
expressing as stem cells and also can
perform as stem cells by differentiating
into different cell and tissue types
all of these are available please reach
out if you ever have any questions or
would like to look into this but we have
a great team of scientists that can
perform all of these experiments for you
so you don't have to
so to summarize real quick we've talked
about our three key steps for limiting
off-target edits in our experiments
first is using a high scoring guide RNA
the way that we can do this is by using
true design to design your guide rnas to
identify the best sequence for guide
with a low off Target profile and high
editing efficiency as well as designing
those sequencing primers and homology
arms for your experiments so you don't
have to do it yourself
next is utilizing the rnp kas9 and guide
RNA approach to help limit off Target
off Target generation with quick removal
of kas9 and next is using the
appropriate endonuclease based off of
your experimental needs whether that's
using a high fidelity cas9 to limit off
Target generation using our CTS cas9 for
cell and gene therapy type approaches or
utilizing our High Fidelity chas9 to
limit those off-target edits
and lastly I hope that I've been able to
demonstrate to you that Thermo Fisher is
here to help we are here to help you
from designing and building your
experiment to delivering and culturing
your cells to the back end with
detecting and validating your edits this
is all done so that we can help you move
on so we can get the edit done and you
can move on to generating important
results and getting your work out there
to the world
so with that I would like to thank you
all for joining me today I hope you
learned a lot and I'd be happy to take
any questions from anyone in the
audience at this time
thank you
great thank you Kevin for that
informative presentation we'll now start
the Q a portion of the webinar so if you
have a question you would like to ask
please do so now again you can click on
the ask a question box located on the
file left of your screen will answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for so let's get started with our first
question
um
so would you recommend crispr or Talent
editing for new Gene editing experiments
okay so um there's a couple
considerations to take with that
um first is have you scanned for guide
rnas using true design and if it is
listing off guides that have very high
scores and low off Target numbers go
with using crispr if you are trying to
do an edit in what we call a Pam desert
which is there's no Pam site close
enough to the area where you're trying
to perform and edit then that would be a
situation where you would want to
utilize a Talon so always check and see
if crispr will work first if not try a
Talon
that's good awesome thanks Kevin
um next question
we actually have a couple of different
questions coming through next one is can
your tool design or the true design tool
guide our design guide RNA that works
across different organisms such as human
and mice Etc
yes currently the true design system is
able to design guides for human mouse
rat round worm
and the last zebrafish
um species as of right now
um if there is a situation where you are
attempting to design guides um for
species that are not otherwise supported
that is something that I could work
one-on-one with you with to help you
design guides to try out and see if
something works
um and we can as Thermo Fisher we are
able to synthesize custom guide RNA
sequences so if that's something that
you're interested in please feel free to
send an email to me or your local Thermo
Fisher sales rep
and we will be able to get a
conversation going to work with you on
that
awesome all right next question Mall
questions on guide RNA so what are the
rules of thumb for guide RNA pick such
as range of score
Etc so I guess consideration on how how
do we go about picking guide rnas from
the tool
sure so always look at the score first
if you you know so true design will give
you a score for each individual guide
RNA and it ranks them in the final list
there but you know highest to lowest
um so always look at the score if you
have a con guyner name that's got a
score in the
60 percent range and above that's still
that is a good guide RNA of course if
you've got one in the 90 range that's a
really good guide RNA
um so that's kind of like the scoring
range that that I look at
um and then the other thing to consider
is the off Target number if that off
Target number is looking a little too
high for you to feel comfortable with
always know that just because that
number is there it does not mean that
every single time you go to do an
experiment that that off Target is going
to happen it's just listing off the
potential a way that you can limit that
risk is by using the guides that have a
high score number and couple that with a
high fidelity cas9 like our true cut
Hi-Fi cas9 which is designed to make it
more difficult for cas9 to make an
off-target edit with guides that are
matching up at other locations in the
genome
um and then in terms of the number of
guides always it's going to base off the
number of guide rnas that true design
design sometimes it can only Design One
based off the site that you're trying to
edit or sometimes it can design two or
maybe multiple I always recommend two to
three for each gene Target
test them out separately in once you've
got all of your reagents to separate
Wells of cells that get treated with
cas9 in each individual guide RNA and
then measure the efficiency of cutting
via genomic cleavage detection and
identify you know are you getting what
kind of percentage of cutting are you
getting with each guide and then you
know move on with the best one or the
best two that have the highest editing
efficiency in your cell type
okay great
um so sort of follow up to that question
oh I guess the second part of that
question
um from the same audience as well is how
do I add an RFP based clonal selection
to my knockout experiment
yes so if you're trying to like tag a
gene with RFP for example which is I
think is is what you're asking yes um so
you would simply choose
um add a fluorescent tag as the type of
experiment you're doing in true design
at the early Parts
um and then it will ask you what type of
fluorescent marker you're trying to add
and it will be able to add it to the C
terminal or the N terminal end of your
protein and that utilizes our I didn't
mention it in this talk because for
time's sake but we have our true tag
kits which are great for doing knock-ins
they come is ready to use synthesized
cassettes so in this case they would
have the RFP Gene the true design system
is going to design those homology arms
to knock it into the exact region where
you're trying to edit as well as it's
going to design a guide RNA that's going
to make a cut right at the edit site
that you're trying to get that insertion
and what's really nice with the true tag
kits is they also give you the option of
picking what antibiotic selection you
would like to use we offer two you can
utilize blastocin or puromycin so you
can pick that and that'll be the version
of the kit that comes to you and then
that gives you the ability to select
yours for yourselves with antibiotic
resistance over time to eliminate
non-edited cells
awesome all right next question is can
you design a guide RNA that works for
both human and mice
ah that would be a little difficult but
not impossible
um true design currently does not give
you a list of if a guide matches up at
the same region for another species
um so that would be something that we
would need to work on one-on-one but we
should be able to identify a guide RNA
sequence that is conserved across human
and mouse for a particular Gene
all right
um so a lot of questions on guide rnas
because the next one is also going to be
on guide rnas but
um what options do I have if I'm limited
to guide RNA with high predicted off
Target in the scoring
sure so a couple things that you can
take into account is okay so you have to
use that guide
again just because that that off Target
number is there doesn't mean that you're
going to generate all of them
um so I would automatically want to test
out
using a high fidelity cas9 like true cut
Hi-Fi that is able to eliminate a lot of
off-target generation based off the way
that that enzyme works
um definitely utilize the ribonuclear
protein approach of delivery because
again that by delivering a high amount
of cas9 early on increases your chances
of getting the On Target cut and then
because that cas9 clears relatively
quickly you're decreasing the risk of it
being able to go off elsewhere within
the genome and make a cut
then I would you would need to follow up
with some vigorous Downstream testing
whether that is next Generation
sequencing of the whole genome or
setting up singer sequencing primers for
each off Target site and then just
screening and scanning the whole entire
pool and seeing how many of those off
targets were actually generated and then
you could get into testing different
conditions with your actual experiment
where you titrate in different
concentrations of cas9 a little lower a
little higher and then also titrate
different concentrations of guide RNA
that you're coupling with the kas9
enzyme because of course if there's a
little bit less guide RNA there's less
chance of it less guider need to match
up elsewhere within the genome to pull
in the cas9 enzyme to make a cut
foreign
so I think we have time for one more
question
um so I'll end with this one
um but so where can I so you have
mentioned a little bit about the
verification of results
um where can I get more information or
at least learn more about some of the um
you know the services that we offer I
think you mentioned like techseek for
example
um where can we get more information or
learn more about those
sure
um so to learn more is go to
www.thermostat.com I wish I had a live
screen here so I could show you but once
you're on the home page of our website
you'll go up to the top where it says
applications and techniques hover your
mouse over that in a giant um fan of
different options will fan Out Below
under the cell biology section you will
find a genome editing
uh hyperlink you'll click on that guy
and that takes you to the home page for
all of our genome editing portfolio and
that includes the true design tool
information about our chasmine enzymes
there's a really nice section about
positive and negative controls for
crispr experiments and talent
experiments as well as information about
transfection suggested protocols as well
as really helpful information for
Downstream validation if you click on
it'll be all that information is listed
on the left hand side of the genome
editing page we also have some
application notes that actually go over
Downstream analysis for different types
of genome editing experiments and
explains all of those and then of course
if you're interested in our customer
services team to do some of the
downstream validation editing for you as
well if you're trying to do a genome
editing experiment and it's just not
working for you and you really need that
edit we have the same team of scientists
have are experts in the field at doing
these types of experiments or the hard
to do edits where they can actually take
on this experiment for you and they can
work on troubleshooting and optimizing
conditions to generate that specific
edit type that you're looking for and
then they can do the downstream
validation in their own laboratory to
check and make sure that the edit is
exactly where it needs to be and be able
to screen out clones of cells that have
off-target edits and then they can
actually send you a nice tube of Frozen
cryopreserved cells that have the edit
of interest that you're looking for so
then you can pick up and start working
in your own lab all of that information
is available on our website and of
course if you ever have any questions
reach out to your local Thermo Fisher
rep whether for your University or for
your site and they will be able to get
you in touch with the right people
okay awesome them
um all right so thank you again Kevin
for your time today we would also like
to thank lab roots and Domo Fisher
Scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcasts before we go I'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and for the interesting
questions any questions that we didn't
have time to address today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration this webcast can be
viewed on demand lab Roots will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who who may
have missed today's live event once
again thank you very much everyone for
your time and have a good rest of your
day